nowadays nebula is fighting for the good  guys after making peace with her sister  gamora and guardians of the galaxy vol  2. she did start out as a villain though  you were going to kill my father you  dared to oppose me  you see what he has turned me into  you kill him i will help you destroy a  thousand planets and although you  wouldn't know it by looking at her the  actress portraying her is actually quite  striking in real life to get into  character as thanos's least favorite  daughter karen gillen donned metallic  and blue makeup shaved off her hair  blacked out her eyes and had a few  android body parts added for good  measure she told screenrant it's really  intense going through this makeup in the  morning but it's amazing i think it  takes about four and a half hours now  but also it's so worth it because i see  bits of footage that we've shot and it's  just so amazing